let's talk about former White House
chief propagandist Steve Bannon there
was a really interesting profile of
Bannon of Breitbart Fame as well in
Vanity Fair it's by Gabriel Sherman
who's really good at these profile
pieces and a recent question has been
how closer Trump and Bannon
since Bannon left the White House what's
bannon's political future what does he
think of the job that Donald Trump is
doing and in one section of this piece
by great Gabriel Sherman and Vanity Fair
Sherman writes that Bannon is reportedly
considering running for president of the
United States which actually just sounds
very unsafe Bannon like but also
interestingly he criticizes Trump Bannon
does as having lost a step and says he's
like an 11 year old child here's a quote
from this piece which reads in October
Bannon called an advisor and said he
would consider running for president if
Trump doesn't run for re-election in
2020 which Bannon has told people is a
realistic possibility in private
conversation since leaving the White
House Bannon said Trump only has a 30%
chance of serving out his term whether
he's impeached or removed by the cabinet
invoking the 25th amendment that
prospect seemed to become more likely in
early December when special counsel
Robert Moeller secured a plea deal from
former national security adviser Michael
Flint
Bannon has also remarked on the toll the
office has taken on Trump telling
advisers his former boss has quote lost
a step
he's like an 11 year old child unquote
Bannon joked to a friend in November CNN
political reporter Rebecca Berg
identified a source that works with
Bannon who says there's no truth
whatsoever to the 20/20 talk that's the
one part to me that is the least
believable I don't see for a second that
Bannon would run for president I need
have no chance to back in April he had
an 11 percent approval rating and that
was well before Charlottesville too he
hasn't done anything that would help his
numbers I guess so I just don't see him
as the type of guy who would even want
to do that but in any case that part at
least by CNN reporter Rebecca Berg we're
told is not true
the idea that Bannon himself only thinks
Trump only has a 30% chance of serving
out his term that is very interesting
but also interesting is this idea that
he sees Trump as an 11 year old child
and I don't know
the truth of each piece of this I do
know that Gabriel Sherman's work is very
very good but it's curious to me how the
post firing phase of Bannon has been
this kind of weird dynamic between
Bannon and Trump when he was first fired
or resigned whatever forced to resign he
said he'd be working Bigley or something
on furthering the Trump agenda all that
stuff but he's actually been hugely
critical of Trump since leaving the
White House Breitbart and Trump seemed
to be feuding a little bit more since
the firing and the White House since
itself has also been criticizing Bannon
as well they supposedly separated on
good terms but the White House has also
been more and more critical of Bannon so
what seems clear to me is that chief of
staff John Kelly wanted Bannon along
with scaramouche II out he was right to
want that these guys were total
political distractions but what about
the political support right because
aside from the public personas of these
folks presumably Bannon supported and
worked with Trump because of Crump's
agenda right he believed in the agenda
so you have to think that he still
supports the agenda of Trump even after
leaving the White House but maybe not
well maybe ban is just being independent
here right he's out of the white house
he can speak his mind now and when
Donald Trump does something that he
disagrees with he can call him out for
it what it suggests to me is that like
Trump a lot of the people involved with
Trump's campaign were not actually in it
because of their political philosophy
aligning with whatever they thought
Donald Trump's political philosophy was
they were in it to advance their careers
and grow their power and their influence
for self-aggrandizement right which are
not really priorities you want for
elected officials even though it's
pretty common that our elected officials
have those as priority and that's who's
Steve Bannon is - absolute off of Andrew
Breitbart dad got him into a good
position there no each Dafa Donald Trump
am I wrong in saying that Bannon is
bigger than ever as a result of having
worked with Trump and we having worked
in the matter of him before working with
Trump yeah that's true I had no idea who
the guy was so it's been very very good
for Steve Bannon that's for sure the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad